henri sterdyniak bonsoir merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
ce soir sur rtl france alors on vient
d'entendre les riches sont devenus
encore plus riche et ce malgré la crise
sanitaire et économique alors comment
est-ce qu'on peut le comprendre
il faut savoir que les taux d'intérêt
sont extrêmement faibles sont nulles
parfois même négatif est temps que la
valeur des entreprises est extrêmement
élevé et donc on se retrouve avec des
entrepôts des ailes à la bourse
française le cac40 qui a augmenté de 25%
par rapport à sa valeur de 2019 qui a
augmenté de 50 % par rapport au creux de
2020 est donc naturellement les
propriétaires de ces entreprises en
bénéficient mais fumant et donc jean
leur fortune si on peut dire qui a
augmenté de 25% par rapport à ce qu'elle
était en fin 2019 alors ça c'est
entreprises du cac 40 elles ont aussi
bénéficié des aides de l'état en france
pendant la pandémie c'était absolument
nécessaire est ce que ces entreprises
risquaient finalement elle aussi de
couler sans ces aides
sur les entreprises ne risque pas de
couler à le gouvernement a fait un choix
on peut plus ou moins disputer le choix
de quoi qu'il en coûte donc il a ouvert
le chômage temporaire à toutes les
entreprises même les entreprises qui
auraient pu
supporter le conserver leurs salariés
durant cette période mais le
gouvernement attend voulu courir de
risques donc le chômage temporaire a été
ouvert à toutes les entreprises et
grosso modo c'est pareil pour toutes les
mesures que ce soit le 10 milliards de
baisses du dax à la production la baisse
de l'impôt sur les sociétés qui parle de
34,3 à 25% pour les aux entreprises tout
ça est donné sans le moindre contrôle
sans condition en matière
maintien d'emplois sans condition en
matière de
lutte pour le changement
climatique et il ya eu quelques
conditions qui ont été donnés en 2019 en
2020 nous pas augmenter les 10 82 pas
augmenter les salaires des cadres
dirigeants dans ce dakar mais les
entreprises du coût sera pas en 2021 et
donc les dirigeants vont avoir en 2021
les revenus très importante que ils ont
pas touché en 2011 a donc tout va bien
pour eux et en même temps tout va bien
pour eux mais il ya plus de 60000 postes
dont près de la moitié en france qui ont
été supprimés là encore comment est-ce
qu'on peut le comprendre
disons qu'ils vont bien parce que parce
que justement ils ont supprimé des
postes le but de ces entreprises de 4 40
entreprises multinationales c'est avant
tout de maximiser le profit des
actionnaires et donc maximiser les
profits des actionnaires ça veut dire
obligatoirement essayer de licenciés en
france et pourra les produire moins cher
dans les pays à bas salaires c'est la
logique même du capitalisme
financier mondialisé
qui qui qui qui joue à plein dans c'est
dans cette affaire lire
les dirigeants des grandes entreprises
ne sont pas des philanthropes ainsi
peuvent effectivement faire des
économies au profit des actionnaires ils
le font et par ailleurs pour donner un
signal fort aux actionnaires résumant
les dividendes les dividendes maintenant
sont supérieurs aux filles d'évidentes
de 2021 sont très supérieurs au profit
de 2004 pour bien montrer aux aux
actionnaires qui en fait tout va bien
pour eux et donc c'est la logique même
du lieu du capitalisme ni faux
présenter une
une façade la plus attrayante possible
pour les actionnaires et par ailleurs
une audemars massivement les dirigera
des entreprises pour remercier les
dirigeants des entreprises de leur bonne
gestion ce qui là aussi est un message
pour les actionnaires alors on se
souvient pourtant pendant cette pandémie
certains se sont pris à imaginer un
capitalisme raisonnable plus vertueux on
parlait de ce fameux monde d'après selon
vous concernant l'économie quel monde
d'après se dessine finalement rien ne
change
et là nous sommes devant une
contradiction importante que notre
société devra résoudre soient
effectivement on s le capitalisme
fonctionne est tel qu'il est avec des
entreprises qui veulent maximiser leurs
profits ce qui suppose maximiser le
chiffre d'affaires ce qui suppose
développer
des besoins toujours grandissants
grandissant chez les consommateurs soit
on prend au sérieux les contraintes
écologiques dit que les entreprises
maintenant elles doivent être gérés en
fonction d'eux des nécessités de
s'étrangler de cette transition
écologique et sociale et à ce moment là
ça veut dire eux ont fait une
planification écologique dans lequel
elle dit aux entreprises votre grande
préoccupation aujourd'hui ça doit être
de réduire l'empreinte écologique de vos
activités de satisfaire les besoins des
consommateurs mais en
réduisant les les comptes rappeler les
dégâts écologiques et en évitant en
évitant de créer des besoins inutiles
chez les consommateurs à sa demande que
effectivement à sa demande un changement
de gouvernance des entreprises avec un
poids beaucoup plus important des
salariés emploient beaucoup plus
important des collectivités locales un
poids beaucoup plus importante des
déchets j'ai façon générale était
et est
le fait qu' il faut se les entreprises
doivent s'inscrire dans la planification
écologique à certains d'entre eux disent
qu'ils sont peu utile il faut le dire
clairement bah désolé il faut réduire
notre activité par contre on a besoin
de développer d'autres activités la
rénovation des logements donc changer de
roche merci beaucoup henri sterdyniak
d'avoir accepté notre invitation sur les
franges le rappelle vous êtes membre des
économistes atterrés